Greetings, developers.
This is Wesley Chun from Google.
Today we're going to cover
the hot topic of where
to put your files in the cloud.
I'm really excited to
introduce and describe
the various storage options that
are available in Google's Cloud
so you can determine which may
be right for you, enabling you
to build that next viral
or even non-viral app.
The first pair of
cloud storage options
we'll cover in this episode
are Google Cloud Storage
and Google Drive.
If you're a
developer, you may be
wondering what is the difference
between Google Drive and Google
Cloud Storage.
I go to many tech
conferences every year,
and this is a question
that comes up regularly.
Aren't they both
storage in the cloud?
Well, the answer is
why yes, they are.
Both utilize the same
underlying storage mechanism
provided by Google's
infrastructure.
But the service offerings
differ both for users as well as
developers.
Let's dig a little
deeper into each.
Google Drive isn't part of
the Google Cloud Platform.
But instead, it's
a service tightly
integrated with the
Google Apps ecosystem.
It's for creating and
editing documents, sharing,
collaborating, and syncing
your docs and personal files
to multiple devices.
Most users interact with
Drive from the web interface
or mobile app.
So yes, there is a
consumer aspect to Drive,
but it's for developers too.
Google Drive provides a
RESTful web API for developers,
both client and server
side, as well as
SDKs for Android and iOS.
These features allow you to
build web or mobile apps that
give your users access to
their Drive files and folders.
What kind of apps can you write?
Spell checking documents,
creating new docs
based on the contents
of a Google sheet.
In fact, in the Google
Drive API documentation,
you'll find open
source starter projects
that edit text files in
Drive folders or unzip
files into a Drive folder.
Click the link to get
access to those samples.
You can also access
the Google Drive API
from Google Apps
Script, which is
JavaScript outside the browser.
It's server side like Node,
but runs on Google servers
and gives users
programmatic access
to data in Google apps
and other Google services,
including Google Drive.
Take a look at the
short code snippet here.
It's just simple JavaScript that
loops through your Google Drive
files and logs the file
names to the console.
If you're familiar with add-ons
for Google Docs and sheets,
they're powered by App Script.
How many of you have
ever edited a Google Doc
simultaneous with other users?
I sure have, and
we do it every day.
Well guess what.
You can create your own apps
that let multiple people sign
on and collaborate together
using the Google Drive Realtime
API.
How cool is that?
Got an app you'd love to see?
There's no need
to wait for Google
to write it when you
can do it yourself.
We empower you to
scratch that itch.
Now that you know
what Google Drive is,
what about Google Cloud Storage?
What do they have in common?
Well, in both cases,
you've got data
that's persistent, fast,
scalable, and highly available.
Both provide access control
for individuals or groups.
However, large scale data such
as backups, archives, big data,
and the processing
of that data is
where Google Cloud
Storage is a better fit.
Cloud storage is part of
the Google Cloud Platform
where services are provided
on behalf of a project
or application,
rather than a user.
Also for some of you,
it's critical to specify
where your data
should be hosted.
And cloud storage supports that.
At this time, you can select
either the US or the EU.
There are many ways by which
you can access Google Cloud
Storage.
Through its website interface,
the command line tool
which is part of the
Google Cloud SDK,
by using the App Engine client
library for your App Engine
apps, from Compute
Engine instances using
built in service
accounts that access
cloud storage data
within the same project,
and the cloud
storage RESTful API.
One of the benefits
from cloud storage
is that you get
access or your data
gets access to other services
in the Google Cloud Platform.
Cloud storage data
can be ingested
into tools which lets you query,
normalize, transform or ETL,
perform analysis on,
or otherwise process
all of your data.
These tools include
Google App Engine apps,
your code running on
Google Compute Engine
virtual machines, Google
BigQuery, which gives you
the ability to analyze
multiple terabytes of data
in mere seconds,
Google Cloud SQL,
our fully managed highly
available relational database
in Google's Cloud,
and Google prediction,
our cloud based machine
learning service.
As you can see, Google Cloud
Storage isn't just for storage.
It's also an entry point.
OK.
One last option for file
storage in the cloud.
Persistent disks.
Think of them as
versatile hard drives
in the cloud available for your
fleet of Google Compute Engine
virtual machines.
While instances boot
from persistent disks,
their content
lives independently
of VM creation and destruction.
Instances can mount
multiple disks.
You can mount persistent
disks on multiple instances,
read only, or read write
if mounted only on one VM.
And you have the
ability to take a point
in time snapshot of
a persistent disk,
then restore it to any Compute
Engine region in the world.
You can do any of these from
Compute Engines web interface,
command line tool, or
it's RESTful web API.
Now that you know about
the different ways
to store files in the
cloud, which you choose
depends on the type
of app or solution
you're building for your users.
If it's working with
documents or personal files,
with the added benefits
of collaboration
and syncing or otherwise
interacting in a Google Apps
domain, Google Drive is
probably the best fit.
If working with a
massive amount of data
with the need to have fine
grained control over who
can access it, or if you're
doing large scale analysis
or computation with that data,
possibly using other Google
Cloud Platform services, I'd
go with Google Cloud Storage.
With cloud storage, you
can easily pop your data
to App Engine,
BigQuery or Cloud SQL.
If that data processing takes
place on Google Compute Engine
instances, you can
easily transfer that data
to Compute Engines
persistent disk just once
and be able to access it
from multiple instances.
All right.
Now that you have
all your options
for file storage in
the cloud, go out there
and build that awesome app.
If you want to learn more,
check out our other DevBytes,
including those which are
data and storage related.
Thanks for tuning in.